CNN ratings have tanked during the
supposed turnaround that they're
involved in CNN's leadership is saying
just be patient be patient but indeed
the numbers don't look good now it's
important to remember cable ratings are
down across the board compared to 2022.
2022 you had the Russian invasion of
Ukraine you had the midterm elections
you had all these different things
everybody's down but CNN is down the
most CNN's ratings are down 61 in prime
time in March Fox is down 27 percent
MSNBC is down by 12 percent now I think
there's one other Factor here which is
there is a continued appetite for
Independent Media people are
increasingly not having time in the day
or having an appetite for standard cable
news and CNN says be patient with us can
they turn it around let me know in the
comments